[Music]
in 1989 the Savior that Taylor Swift was
born the world met at even Telluride
girl whose songs got even more stuck in
your head
The Little Mermaid travel under the sea
to the whimsically fascist kingdom of
Atlantica where some fish were allowed
to swim free while others are forced to
drag the ruling class around in their
chariots or use their own bodies as
instruments and meet Ariel a half-naked
fifteen-year-old
and confirmed hoarder follow along
fish-out-of-water story as she falls in
love with the human Prince Eric
because he's hot he's very handsome
isn't he he's so beautiful the only
thing swimming in their way is the most
clearly evil villain in the Disney
Pantheon Ursula the sea witch no she's a
demon an old witch who keeps the
tortured souls of her victims in her
front yard eat seafood and hates Ariel's
whole family but none of that will stop
Ariel from trading away her voice for a
pair of legs in a 72-hour time limit to
French a stranger he is quite a catch
isn't it get swept up in a fantastical
romance where love conquers all is my
love you mean acting like a clueless
mute brat so an older guy will make out
with you and enjoy the vintage Disney
classic with an equally vintage message
for today's young girls look pretty you
go to Luke's old beast you look
wonderful
but without my voice your books
you surround yourself with brands who
are dumber and fatter than you abandon
your family to marry a guy you diss Matt
and if you're not happy with the
contract you sign without even reading
get your fiance to murder the person who
outsmarted you so strap on your fins for
the musical you can't help but sing
along to featuring songs like the dumb
mermaid saw the obligatory villains are
exploring bad guy songs slow blend so
blah but to move the plot along the
villain has to have a song but in the
soundtrack it gets kill the shouldn't
you ask for consent first song the
traumatize your kids are killing your
children zzzz even Zaza heroes are all
like if they made sushi of Nemo and Dory
you'd have something as messed up as and
the one we're about to get stuck in
[Music]
[Applause]
story she's well seashells wide Aladdin
pinkie Minaj fish the closest thing this
movie has to look black person Jack
Gandalf and whiny
Nemo the little waistline
this movie would have played out way
differently if her top F was a fish
instead be sure to subscribe for more
honest trailers big thanks to our
friends a navy but for their help with
the music go subscribe and tell them
Sebastian sent you get off my lawn
fluffy thunder Winkle hello I am baymax
your personal healthcare companion
I don't fear death death fears me Harry
did you put your name in the Goblet of
Fire I'm all about that bass about that
bass bout that bass no treble